[Música]
en el marco de la décima cumbre de
países de Norteamérica los líderes de
Canadá México y Estados Unidos dieron
una declaración conjunta en la que
reiteraron la necesidad de mantener la
unidad para hacer frente a los retos
económicos comerciales migratorios y de
lucha contra el narcotráfico en la
región comidas a la integración
continental
en Perú El Congreso aprobó el voto de
confianza al gabinete del Primer
Ministro Alberto otarola y ante los
violentos enfrentamientos y la muerte de
18 personas en medio de las protestas en
contra de la presidenta Dina boluarte su
gobierno decretó el toque de queda en
puno escenario de la crisis política
el supremo brasileño ordenó el arresto
del jefe de seguridad pública de
Brasilia tras el asalto a los edificios
del poder público por manifestantes
bolsonaristas más de 700 personas
permanecen detenidas por los desmanes
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
México donde se reunieron los
mandatarios de los tres países de
Norteamérica y anunciaron acuerdos en
materia económica así como la creación
de un grupo de trabajo para sustituir y
planear importaciones de otras naciones
y atender las causas que generan la
migración en todas las Américas en
cuanto a la lucha contra las drogas el
presidente mexicano prometió que la
guardia nacional controlará el tráfico
de fentanilo hacia el norte Samuel
Salgado nos cuenta más
Los tres amigos reunidos el Primer
Ministro de Canadá Justin trudeo el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden y
de México Andrés Manuel López Obrador
entregaron las conclusiones de su primer
encuentro en la Ciudad de México donde
abordar un temas de migración cambio
climático y narcotráfico baiden destacó
la importancia de la relación trilateral
para atender estos asuntos
con estos aliados y socios más cercanos
ninguno es más cercano que México y
Canadá para asumir los mayores desafíos
que enfrenta la región francamente
también el mundo porque ya no puede
haber ninguna duda ninguna en el mundo
interconectado de hoy no podemos
encerrarnos en muros precisamente López
Obrador informó que lograron acuerdos
migratorios y celebró las políticas
canadienses que ya le han permitido a
25.000 mexicanos trabajar en su
territorio a su vez destacó que el
presidente estadounidense no haya
construido ni un metro del muro
fronterizo
ahora
usted es el primer presidente de Estados
Unidos en mucho tiempo
que no ha construido ni un metro
de muro
Y eso
se lo agradecemos
aunque no les guste
a los
conservadores
el presidente mexicano anunció además la
creación de un comité conjunto en
Norteamérica para la sustitución de
importaciones también
la integración económica y comercial
como ya lo expresé
dejando atrás el intervencionismo
hegemónico frente al desafío del cambio
climático el Primer Ministro canadiense
celebró que sus homólogos prometieron
cumplir con los compromisos del acuerdo
de París debemos tomar partido en la
acción climática los gobiernos y los
sectores privados deben trabajar
conjuntamente para cumplir los objetivos
climáticos de 2030 además resaltó que
los tres jefes de estado de Norteamérica
se comprometieron a proteger los
derechos de las mujeres y niñas
especialmente de las indígenas de sus
países
[Música]
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden dijo que está sorprendido por el
hallazgo de una serie de documentos
clasificados como confidenciales en una
antigua oficina suya en Washington
Aunque Este descubrimiento se hizo en
noviembre la noticia se conoció Solo
hasta ayer vayan dijo que él y su equipo
están cooperando en una revisión de lo
sucedido y que no sabe qué es lo que hay
en los documentos que datan de cuando
fue vicepresidente de Barack Obama las
críticas llovieron sobre el mandatario
quien había tilda irresponsable a su
antecesor Donald Trump en cuya casa en
Florida se encontraron registros
oficiales el año pasado el expresidente
instó a registrar las casas de baile
en otras noticias de Estados Unidos al
menos 17 personas han muerto en
California desde que inició el año
debido a las tormentas que azotan al
estado y que han provocado inundaciones
en la ciudad de Fresno se pudieron
observar deslizamientos de tierra que
han provocado el cierre de vías y en
Santa Bárbara por ejemplo las calles se
convirtieron en ríos más de 33 millones
de californianos se han visto amenazados
por el clima según el servicio
meteorológico nacional los vientos
alcanzaron más de 60 kilómetros por hora
y han causado estragos derribando
árboles y afectando la red eléctrica
dejando a más de 180.000 hogares y
negocios sin el servicio de energía
en Perú El Congreso aprobó el voto de
confianza al gabinete del Primer
Ministro Alberto otarola de otro lado la
fiscalía anunció una investigación en
contra de la presidenta Dina boluarte
por las muertes que se han registrado en
las protestas entre diciembre y lo que
va de enero el gobierno declaró el toque
de queda en puno Ciudad andina en donde
se han presentado violentos choques
entre manifestantes y la policía que han
dejado hasta el momento 18 personas
fallecidas por lo que fueron decretados
tres días de duelo veamos el informe de
la jurel
la región de puno en el sur de Perú está
en el ojo del huracán en menos de 24
horas al menos 18 personas perdieron la
vida en las manifestaciones contra la
presidenta Gina boluarte el gobierno
decretó un toque de queda nocturno de
tres días en este territorio la
inmovilización social obligatoria en
puno por el plazo de tres días desde las
veinte horas
de la mañana
esto en salvaguarda de la vida de la
integridad y de la libertad de todos los
ciudadanos con nacionales de puno entre
tanto en el congreso el Primer Ministro
Alberto tarro la presentó una votación
sobre el nuevo gabinete pero en la
sesión varios legisladores rechazaron su
discurso de protección del pueblo de su
lado la congresista Ruth Luque presentó
a la fiscalía una denuncia penal contra
la presidenta y su gabinete por
homicidio calificado y lesiones graves
en calidad de autores mediatos en
vísperas de una huelga nacional la
organización de Naciones Unidas llamó a
luz manifestantes a mostrar moderación y
pacifismo e instó a las autoridades
peruanas a respetar los Derechos Humanos
reiteramos nuestro llamamiento a que las
fuerzas de seguridad cumplan las normas
de derechos humanos y garanticen que
solo se hace uso de la fuerza cuando es
estrictamente necesario y en tal caso
respetando plenamente los principios de
legalidad precaución y proporcionalidad
desde diciembre al menos siete personas
han fallecido en los enfrentamientos
entre policías y manifestantes el
gobierno anunció que este miércoles se
ha decretado un día de duelo nacional
en Brasil el tribunal supremo ordenó el
arresto del exministro de justicia de
Yael bolsonaro Anderson Torres quien
estaba a cargo de la seguridad pública
en Brasilia y fue destituido el domingo
cuando Seguidores del exmandatario
asaltaron las sedes de los tres poderes
un pescado brasileño pidió bloquear los
bienes del funcionario mientras se
determina su participación en los hechos
entre tanto las autoridades informaron
que 599 de los arrestados tras los
disturbios del domingo en Brasilia
Fueron liberados por razones
humanitarias previamente indicaron que
interrogaron a unos mil detenidos
algunos dijeron que seguirán en las
calles
fuimos traicionados por el ejército
brasileño nos entregaron a la policía
éramos la resistencia
lucharemos de nuevo descansaremos y nos
prepararemos para la nueva pelea Porque
si creen que nos van a intimidar con eso
están completamente equivocados
nadie rompió nada fueron los infiltrados
quienes lo rompieron están culpando a
Los Patriotas pero fueron los
infiltrados los que rompieron todo nos
prepararon una trampa
él
prepararonas la vicepresidenta de
Colombia Francia Márquez denunció a
través de su cuenta de Twitter lo que
denominó como un nuevo intento de
atentar contra su vida su equipo de
seguridad desactivó y destruyó un
artefacto explosivo que fue hallado en
la ruta hacia su residencia familiar
ubicada en el departamento del cauca en
el suroccidente del país
integrantes de mi equipo de seguridad
hallaron un artefacto con más de 7 kilos
de material explosivo en la vía que
conduce a mi residencia familiar en la
Vereda de yolombó en Suárez cauca el
mismo fue destruido de manera controlada
por personal antiexplosivos de la sijin
hasta aquí este Informativo en France 24
Gracias por acompañarnos pero los
invitamos a que continúen con toda
nuestra programación y puedan seguir la
actualización de nuestras noticias a
través de nuestra página web triple W
punto franz24.com
[Música]